-Our next guest
is a fantastic comedian
who used to write here
at "Late Night."
Her book, "Unreliable Narrator:
Me, Myself, and Impostor
Syndrome"
is on sale now.
Please welcome back to the show
Aparna Nancherla, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi, Aparna.
-Hey!
-I'm so happy
to have you back here.
You wrote on the show, 2015.
-Allegedly.
-Allegedly. Yes.
-You did have an A-plus joke
that you remember fondly.
-I do.
It was a visual joke,
which means, you know,
the punch line
is a reveal of a picture.
And you know me.
I love pictures.
-You do love pictures.
That's what we always
said about you.
-But yes.
-We dug it up
and we would love to show it.
-Okay, great.
-Because I will say this.
It's one of those great jokes,
it ages very well.
-Okay, great.
-I should let our audience
know this is pre-pandemic
if you're wondering
why I'm dressed like
an actual talk show host.
[ Laughter ]
Here's Aparna's wonderful joke.
Pope Francis began his tour
of the United States today,
and he kicked it off
in style with a stop
at his favorite restaurant,
Pope Yes.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I -- Okay.
I remember because, you know,
we run the jokes ahead
in the meeting during the day
and the look in your eyes
when you saw the sign
Popeyes and you were like,
"Oh, Pope Yes,"
and I was like, "Yeah!"
[ Laughter ]
I was so excited because,
you know, monologue writer,
you write jokes every day.
And, like, the thing about me
that I quickly learned,
I only have about
one or two good ideas a week.
and then the rest of the week
I celebrate those ideas.
So, you know, I was really
struggling to come up.
And that Pope Yes, I was like,
"I didn't believe
in God before, but..."
[ Laughter ]
-Pope Yes.
-Pope Yes. Pope Yes.
-Now, when you were on the show,
did you ever think
you would come back
and be a guest on the show?
-No, not under
positive circumstances.
[ Laughter ]
-You thought we would drag you
back in here
for an investigation?
-Well, it was like, you know,
"she got canceled inevitably.
Let's find out more."
-Oh, yeah.
You would be canceled publicly
and we'd bring you back sort of
for a public hearing.
-Yes. Yes. It would be like my
first apology to the public.
-I got you.
Well, I'm certainly glad
we're not using
your time here for that
because you have written
a fantastic book.
-Thank you.
-And it is about --
it is about anxiety
and depression
and impostor syndrome
and self-doubt.
-Yes.
-Now, even people,
competent people I know
when they write books,
that is when, if they've
never had self-doubt,
that's when it creeps up.
So how hard was it for you
to have that very real
feeling of self-doubt
to then write a book which
brings on self-doubt so often?
-Yeah. I mean, I decided
to write the book
because I was struggling
with self-doubt
so acutely
in my actual life.
Like, I had sort of had some
moderate success as a comedian.
I realized the more
opportunities I got,
the worse my anxiety and, like,
impostor syndrome got.
So I was like,
you know, self-doubt.
If you have so much to say,
you do some work,
write me -- write me a book.
[ Laughter ]
But the thing
with self-doubt,
it's not a good collaborator.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, as soon
as I started writing,
it was just like,
"Who are you to write a book?"
You know, it's just like...
[ Laughs ]
Like, it didn't like --
I tried -- In writing the book,
I tried to be like, okay,
I'm going to learn
to work with it.
But, like,
even before I came out
for this interview,
I was just like, you know,
trying to think
of positive things.
I was like, "Be yourself."
And then my self-doubt
was just like,
"Who are you?"
[ Laughter ]
-It's not helpful.
-Not helpful.
-A thing you did, which I
imagine --
I don't know if it was
because you wanted to do it
for the readers or you wanted to
do it for yourself,
but you give
your depression a name.
-Yes.
-And that was I guess
you didn't want to have
to keep writing "depression."
-Yeah, because, you know,
depression doesn't have
a great reputation.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like it's earned
its bad reputation.
-Yes, yes, yes.
But I wanted to put
some more levity in it,
so I just started
calling it Brenda.
-Yeah.
-Because I felt like that was
the perfect amount
of, like, casual,
but also you sort of are like,
"Oh, Brenda's here again."
You know, like,
you're not so mad,
but you're not psyched
she's there either.
She's kind of one of those
friends where you're like,
"Do we really like each other?
I don't know.
She's always here."
[ Laughter ]
-The book has
very funny moments.
There's this sort of levity,
I expect,
knowing you as a writer
and a stand-up,
but how is writing a book like
this different from stand-up?
Did you find it
completely different?
-Yeah, I mean,
I felt like -- I feel like
with writing stand-up,
you know, you get your setup,
your punch line,
you have kind of a clean out
at the end.
And I feel with a lot of these
topics like mental health
or body image
or like productivity,
like, there's such messy
ongoing internal topics for me
that I kind of didn't
always want to give myself
that out of a punch line
and just kind of live
in the mess a little bit more.
But now I'm noticing
in promoting the book,
it's a little weird
because it's like
instead of solving
my self-doubt,
I just felt like it
ended the book
just like covered
in my own crap.
And then I'm just like, "Look at
me, I'm covered in crap.
Don't you want to know why?
Read my book."
[ Laughter ]
-You've talked about
being on stage,
and obviously a lot
of stand-up comedians
when they're trying
new material will bomb.
-Yes.
-That is an important part
of the process.
-Yes.
-But you would
sort of preplan for bombing.
-[ Laughs ] Yes. Yes.
-You would sort of just
have things ready to go in case.
-Yeah, I was like,
I got to have lines
for when it doesn't go well
because that is going to be
part of my journey, you know?
So, like sometimes
if no one's saying anything,
I'd be like,
"Oh, you're laughing so hard,
no sound is coming out.
It's one of those laughs,
you know?"
Or "Oh, this is something we can
both journal about later,"
you know, like, just because,
you know, when you're bombing,
it's like you're uncomfortable.
But the audience is also
uncomfortable watching you fail.
Like, it's not fun
for them either.
-No.
-Yeah.
-That is the thing.
-When you're like,
when people are like,
"That was a bad audience,"
I'm like,
"They were also having
a terrible time."
-And they paid to have
a terrible time,
so they lost money
and had a bad time.
-I was a guest.
You did a podcast for Audible
called "Introverts:
A Survival Guide."
-Yes.
-And I really enjoyed
talking to you.
Did you enjoy
doing that podcast?
Do you feel like --
Were you setting out
to make a podcast
for people
that were facing the same
difficulties you were having?
-Yeah, I mean,
I'm an introvert
and I feel like
I've always lived very much
from the inside out,
and I will say
I mostly interviewed
introverts for the podcast.
And then you were kind of
the surprise guest at the end
where it was like,
surprise,
you're going to interview
an extrovert to learn some tips.
And guess what.
It's a professional interviewer.
Good luck!
[ Laughter ]
So yeah, it was
pretty much my nightmare.
-Yeah, well, I had a great time.
[ Laughter ]
I want you to know it was not
my nightmare.
The book is wonderful.
The podcast is also wonderful.
And thank you so much
for being back.
It is a joy to have you.
-Thank you for having me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aparna Nancherla, everybody.
"Unreliable Narrator"
is on sale now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."